welcome back to las vegas now for many
parents getting used to making lunches
for school might take some time so our
friends at smith's food and drug the
sponsors of this segment are sharing
some ideas to make your life easier
hello everybody i'm chef jeff from
smiths it's back to school time and it's
that time of year where we start to
think about the ideas to keep our kids
happy during their school time with
their lunches and everything like that
and smith of course has tons of options
for you to to keep your kids happy lots
of snacks and on the go things and as
you're taking these things through the
checkout line the cashier should be
asking you about a great great way to
partner up with smith's to help those
children who are in need and that is
through these special little lunch kits
if they'll ask you to donate a dollar
fifty and that dollar fifty will pay for
one of these lunch kits that will go to
schools where kids are in need and then
the smiths will also match your donation
so you'll your dollar fifty will turn
into two of these which is a really cool
thing so take advantage of that when the
cashier asks of you
to do that i also wanted to show you a
couple of ideas to keep keep things
light and fun for your kids for their
school lunches and that is with turning
their everyday sandwiches into something
fun we're going to turn those into tacos
and so how you do that is you get a
slice of bread and you get a big circle
mold if you have one and then just go
ahead and cut that out like so
and then what you're going to do is
you're going to flatten it out kind of
and that's going to be your little taco
shell
and this is where you can have fun and
ask your kids what they want in there
and you can have a variety of different
things i have a couple examples of what
you can do i have some nutella and you
can just throw some strawberries on that
and that's a great way to provide
something healthy for your kids and fun
and you just fold it over and you've got
these little cool little tacos right
and then i have a strawberry banana or
not strawberry but peanut butter and
banana one of my favorite combinations
and just throw some bananas and then
it's a great way to be healthy as well
with your kids and have something fun
this last one i just wanted to show you
just throw some mayonnaise and some meat
and cheese
really delicious
and fun and your kids again will will
love this and they'll be excited to show
all their friends they're cool
the cool idea that their mom had for
them
and then let's pack lunch you can also
find these uh smith has a wide variety
of these
coolers that you can have and they're
mostly insulated and which is a nice
thing these days
and some of them have these bento box in
them like this and so let's pack my
lunch i've got these nice little simple
truth drink pouches some nice healthy
chips we'll throw in a an orange maybe a
granola bar and then we'll pack up one
of our
taco sandwiches i'm going to go for the
str or the banana and peanut butter
because that's my favorite
okay
lunch is ready to go the kids will be
happy again remember that uh as you go
through the checkout line to donate that
dollar fifty and uh donate these uh
wonderful lunch kits to to those kids
who are in need it's a great way to get
involved in helping out in your
community and and a great way for you
and smith to partner up in that thank
you so much for watching uh thank you
for shopping and we will see you all
next time bye everybody
thanks again to smith's food and drug
for sponsoring this segment for more
information visit the web page on your
screen